on February the 24th International
efforts to prevent the Russian invasion
of Ukraine failed
the Biden administration's response
sanctioned Moscow and give Keith
billions in military assistance
even so the war ground on through
December President Putin has failed at
defeating Ukraine on the battlefield
he has failed at his land grabs in the
south and east
he's failed at erasing Ukraine's borders
its identity its people
it's resilience
the U.S and other Western countries
looked for ways to punish Moscow oil
price caps travel and business sanctions
Gathering evidence of alleged human
rights violations and war crimes they
also used the war to expand NATO's
membership but isolating Russia wasn't
as easy as the U.S had hoped I think all
wars end in some kind of negotiated
solution at some point the costs so far
are not high enough for Russia to
conclude that there that it's in their
interest to stop Ukrainian people have a
lot of backbone that said the U.S has
made it clear it will not send American
troops to help ukrainians fight the war
in Ukraine wasn't the only foreign
policy crisis facing the Biden
Administration it also had to put a lot
of time and energy into what it calls
its number one foreign policy priority
the rise of China
Washington says it wants to compete with
Beijing not contain it but it is worried
about China's efforts to dominate
economic and Military relations around
the world while ignoring its human
rights obligations
the Pentagon recently unveiled its
newest stealth bomber the B-21 with this
warning the U.S is watching China's
every move America's defense
will always be rooted in deterring
conflict
so we are again making it plain to any
potential foe
the risk and the cost of aggression
far outweigh any conceivable gains
Anthony blinken visited countries in
Southeast Asia three times in 2022 he
also endorsed increased U.S military
support for Taiwan and he went to
Australia to bolster the new security
alliance with it and the United Kingdom
blinken also made four trips to the
Middle East a region where Beijing has
tried to build closer economic ties
there are a lot of opportunities for U.S
firms for U.S businesses for U.S persons
to to engage with interact with do
business with every day with people in
these parts of the world China's just
taken the lead on that because they see
an opportunity efforts to recalibrate
ties with Saudi Arabia were complicated
despite a presidential trip to Saudi
Arabia in July the U.S is now reviewing
its economic and political relationship
with Riyadh because of a rift over
global oil prices
critics have also attacked Washington's
decision to not let the fiance of
jamalica sugji Sue Crown Prince Mohammed
bin saliman for the journalist's murder
in 2018.
the U.S made little progress in
resurrecting the nuclear deal with Iran
it's not clear when a new round of
negotiations will happen
prospects for peace talks between
Israelis and Palestinians were also dim
though late in 2022 a new special
representative for Palestinian Affairs
was appointed
the U.S and its allies couldn't stop
North Korea's nuclear weapons program or
even prevent it from test firing dozens
of ballistic missiles
and despite the Anarchy on the streets
of Haiti's Capital the U.S and other
countries have yet to decide if they
will send in armed troops this at the
request of president
looming over all of this though is the
war in Ukraine a challenge the U.S has
argued must be defeated if respect for
the rule of law and for
self-determination is to endure Rosalind
Jordan Al Jazeera Washington